thank you as has been noted by others
women are in short supply and subjects
for this conference women are seldom the
block that makes a difference in the
political outcome women are not often
candidates themselves and so are not
often elected a few Mormon women have
been notably involved ivy Baker priest
was the u.s. treasurer from 1953 to 1961
and her signature appeared on all US
currency then issued Paula Hawkins
served in the US Senate from Florida
from 1980 to 1986 Esther a grits and
Peterson was a consumer advocate both as
an activist and as an official undersell
several US presidents but in legal
realms women have traditionally been
considered extensions of their husbands
and fathers rather than individuals in
their own right although there have been
three recent female secretaries of state
in the United States political women are
more often seen as the silent
tight-lipped supporters of their
husbands caught in flagrant misbehavior
Mormon women largely considered obedient
to Authority and lacking in ambition to
challenge male leadership would be
considered unlikely to have spoken out
on political matters however you Tong
miss serif young is that not a great
name and Nisa Brigham Young was the
first woman to vote with full suffrage
in the United States she was the first
woman at the polls in Salt Lake City on
February 21st 1870 the Utah women also
voted in the general state election in
September 1870 the territorial
legislature of Wyoming had passed the
women's suffrage measure on December
10th 1869 just two months before Utah
passed hers on February 12th 1870 and
Utah then had an election first Utah's
women voted from 1870 until 1887
when the right of suffrage which had
been granted by the territorial governor
and Legislative Assembly was withdrawn
by the National United States Congress
in the edmonds Tucker act as part of the
effort to combat Utah's polygamy Utah's
women voted for 17 years and then did
not vote for 19 years
when Utah became a state in 1896 Utah
entered with equal suffrage her women
gained the vote lost it and got it back
many years before 1920 when women's
suffrage became the law of the land
Mormon women have acted politically on a
number of occasions mostly at the
request of the men in their church
sometimes in opposition they have left
lasting records of their activity in
print and in memory and today I want to
recall a few of the stirring voices some
of those women have spoken with their
rhetoric is often thrilling and
heartfelt as they speak for their own
positions against real and assumed
opposition for my longer paper I'll
speak on four occasions
when Mormon women spoke on political
matters for this shorter paper today I
will speak on three the consideration of
the Cullen bill at the time of suffrage
was established in 1870 the undated Utah
suffrage songbook of the 1880s or 90s
and thoughts on California's Proposition
8 in 2007 in 1870 shall be more column
representative from Illinois introduced
stringent and e mormon legislation in
the legislature of the United States the
Cullen bill prompted the Utah Mormon
women to hold mass meetings protesting
its passage the women showed themselves
as effective political speakers as well
as voters their remarks have been
partially credited with the defeat of
the bill historians have noted that
Utah's women suffrage was instigated to
combat plural marriage by enlisting
Mormon women to fight their male and
church induced oppression if so the mass
meetings are evidence of a failed
strategy the Cullen bill passed the
National House of Representatives but
died in the Senate roud Lee opposed by
the militant Mormon women in the Salt
Lake Tabernacle the Mormon feminists
passionately defended their way of life
and perhaps the best speech by Mormon
High Priestess and Relief Society
president s as she liked to be referred
to Eliza R snow contains many ringing
phrases she forcefully contends that
women stay in Mormonism by choice that
they could leave it will that they have
more freedom than anyone else they
choose to stay as the best possible
living situation Snow contends that
Mormon women are so devoted to their
cause that they have willingly done what
they could never have been forced to do
I love this reasoning they are not only
not enslaved but they have chosen and
prefer to do harder work than slaves and
here's a taste of that speech I will now
ask this intelligent assembly of ladies
do you know of any place on the face of
the earth where women has more
liberté where she enjoys more high and
glorious privileges as she does here as
a latter-day Saint know the history of
this people would show it once that the
part which woman has acted in it could
never have been performed against her
will
amid the many distressing scenes through
which we have passed the privations and
hardships consequent on our expulsion
from state to state and our location in
an isolated barren wilderness the women
in this church have performed and
suffered what could never have been born
and accomplished by slaves these refined
women identify themselves as to help
meets and counselors to their husbands
in tones that suggest the declaration of
independence where are we the stupid
degraded heartbroken beings that we have
been represented silence might best
become us but as women of God women
filling high and responsible positions
performing sacred duties women who stand
not as dictators but as counselors to
their husbands and who in the purest
noblest sense of refined womanhood being
truly their help meets we not only speak
because we have the right but justice
and humanity demand that we should the
Proceedings of this mass meeting were
published in 1870 and I think that this
strong early feminist cradle stands with
Elizabeth Cady Stanton 1848 declaration
of sentiments woman women lost the
franchise in 1887 when the federal
Edmonds Tucker act as stringent anti
polygamy bill snatched back that
privilege by preventing all Utah women
from voting under extensive pressure the
Mormon Church discontinued plural
marriage in 1890 and Utah joined the
union in 1896 with women's suffrage a
more lighthearted contribution for
Mormon women was the Mormon suffrage
songbook as publication of words to be
sung to familiar tunes at suffrage
rallies this undated songbook
ten cents would have been published
between 1887 and 1896 I wish that I had
proposed a singing session for this
conference where we could have sung some
of these lively songs but I can't resist
at least bringing up one the best of
these songs is called women arise no
author is credited but it has an LDS
tune hope of Israel by William claisen
it's short the words and music work well
the attractive perkiness rather than the
super virtuous tone often seen make it a
winner and it's short hole goes like
this I'll read the first verse freedom's
daughter roused from slumber see the
curtains are withdrawn which so long thy
mind hath shrouded loath the day begins
to dawn now I'm going to sing the chorus
woman rise thy pen and sword sit though
in the dust no more sees the scepter
hold the ban equal width I brother man
now I'm gonna read you the second verse
and then you have to sing the chorus
okay this is the second verse truth and
virtue be thy model temperance liberty
and peace light shall shine in darkness
Spanish love shall reign oppression
ceased remember woman rise thy penance
or sit thou in the dust no more woman
rise thy pen and sword
said though in the dust snowboard sees
the scepter hook scepter hold the band
equal with thy brother man sees the
scepter hold the ban equal width I
brother man
let's do it one more time
became ready and woman rise thy penance
or sidonis said though in the dust no
more sees the scepter sees the scepter
hold of fan equal with now that's a good
song breaks out in many ways but so many
movements and revolutions ride on the
felicitous phrase and Mormon women have
not been lacking and creating those
phrases which they have been involved in
they have been involved in political
manners and here I would have spoken
about the e ra and the iwi but I've cut
that section because of time limitations
to ban a recent request I'm moving right
on to Proposition 8 which Joanne is
talking about to a recent request for
political help occurred in California
when the church solicited funds and
involvement to build support for
proposition 8 a measure to support
traditional marriage Eliza R snow
speaking publicly spoke with
breathtaking surety and conviction the
women's voices that follow our silent
voices recorded in the quiet rooms for
the Claremont Oral History Program and
used here anonymously they showed out
ambiguity nuanced few of the voices
recorded wholeheartedly supported the
issue some rejected it as a suitable
position for the church some cited the
pain of others one sister said I just
felt that church had no business getting
involved in that they were trying to get
people to go out in canvassed
neighborhoods and vote against it I
wouldn't have gone out there on a bet I
mean I just did not think that the
church should have been involved
I just wasn't the church's place I
disagreed with it totally some were more
critical and dismissive Mormons were
pulled into political activity church
buildings were used for political
purposes heavy preaching supported a
definition of marriage is between a man
and woman therefore against any marriage
between two people of the same gender
those unwilling to join the battle were
considered to have failed a religious
test the pain of the action brought to
others as well as the ruptures and
relationships were cited by those who
opposed the bill I have a really good
friend at school who is a lesbian she
got married over the summer and found
out about my support of Proposition 8
and it pretty much destroyed our
friendship
we'd been really good friends for about
15 years
we are collegial now but were not
friends anymore that was very painful
for both of us she just can't understand
how I could belong to a church that
hates her another sister made obedience
her major concern she felt the campaign
overreached but if asked she would have
complied I am so glad I do not live in
California and have to go door to door
it appears to me and I can't even point
to anything specific but it appears to
me that the church learned something
from what happened in California I don't
think they will ask other states to
fight the battle that way but I'm
obedient would I do it I know I would
but it would be very hard very very hard
there's a lot of obedience involved this
issue figured in the narratives of the
number of women taking on a more causal
relationship to daily life here are some
of their stories during Proposition 8
the Mormon Church mobilized to promote
the proposition that would prevent gay
marriage this was an extremely painful
moment for me as a Mormon because I saw
good people mobilized to do something
that I felt was really at heart
unchristian and unkind people want to
marry how is that a bad thing we should
be affirming this in every way at first
I went to church every week eventually I
couldn't continue going to church the
breaking point came when a fulfill award
member referred to Mormons who didn't
support proposition 8 as tears that
needed to be separated from the wheat so
I was a chair
huh I couldn't handle it anymore I
retreated and found my refuge at the
United Church of Christ they are an open
and affirming congregation the pastor is
gay and has a lifelong partner I loved
their services and their sermons and
their music I felt a real connection
with the people there and they were good
to me I'll always be grateful to them
for being a refuge during the
Proposition eight crisis here's another
story proposition 8 was bad proposition
8 was really bad
I left DC in July and they had literary
literally just read the letter over the
pulpit in my sacrament meeting they're
saying the elections are coming up in
the fall we do not hand out the word
list we do not get involved this is DC
that's what was read in my ward then I
show up in Claremont California and they
are reading over the pulpit the letter
from the First Presidency saying you
must get involved in your community to
help pass Proposition 8 and I'm thinking
wait a minute these don't match here a
doesn't match B in fact they're complete
opposites we had a woman in the ward who
is in charge of signups to do polling in
the neighborhood they were going around
asking people how they would vote
supposedly they weren't trying to
influence but at the same time they
would say well here's our take on this I
can't even remember if we were yes or no
that's how much I didn't want to be a
part of things every week the women in
charge would pass a list around and
people would sign up to go I wouldn't do
it in part because I have friends who
are gay and I couldn't make it work in
my head well one day in Cindi school
class this woman bore her testimony and
cried for more than 15 minutes and I'm
not exaggerating
aiding because again I was sitting there
thinking how much longer do I have to
sit here before I can actually get up
and leave because I can't breathe
I was basically having an anxiety attack
I had to leave the room and she kept
going I couldn't deal with it and then
they had a fifth Sunday meeting the one
lawyer in the wolf's Ward explained what
was going to happen if prop 8 didn't
pass they handed out
copies of the letter from the First
Presidency and I was sitting in the back
with a couple of radical friends I
finally got the letter and it basically
said we believe in marriage between a
man and a woman do it you can period it
didn't say go polling it didn't say
stand outside of the polling places and
hold signs it didn't say any of this it
said do what your conscience tells you
to do and I thought okay all the stuff
that the lawyer is telling us may come
to pass I'm not gonna argue with him but
at the same time none of this is in this
letter none of this and I did what I
could
I voted because that's what was asked of
me and that one was difficult I think
sometimes we tend to take whatever is
political and try to fit it into our
theology but that's not what the letter
said they told us that the stake had to
donate money but that's not what the
letter said the letter said do what you
can if the stake interprets it as we
need to raise money to support this well
that's fine if that's what they believe
but the letter to me said do what you
can for the women that was handing out
the sign-up sheets bearing her testimony
that was what she could do more power to
her but don't do it around me here's
another story
our middle child and second son is a
homosexual he came out to us when he was
18 after a year at BYU the fact that he
said he was gay was no surprise to me it
was a surprise to his dad I think that
the church has not handled the issue
well I think frankly the church was
wrong in California regarding the
same-sex marriage I do not see it's
causing any damage to traditional
couples it was easy enough for the
church to speak against homosexuality
and assure members that it was an
inclination a choice and that could be
changed now the church no longer claims
that but the fact is that homosexuals
still do not feel welcome in the church
unless they stay tightly closeted just
recently we had a women's statewide
meeting my
and I were asked to speak about same-sex
attraction I've made it a point to speak
openly about it to anyone who is willing
to listen after our son came out I said
it was okay it took him a while to talk
about to his closest friends it took
courage to speak to them so he wouldn't
lose them since then I've made it a
point that I would speak but sadly it is
still something that's hidden we know a
number of people who are gay or lesbian
and a surprising number of families who
don't ever ever mention it it is an
unnamed problem they may mention a child
who may be doing drugs but never one who
is gay no I don't think the church is
handling it will I understand that it's
a difficult situation it's not only our
church it said their churches as well
but when you say we love them and they
are welcome they're not really welcomed
church members are uncomfortable about
asking gates children to stay with them
if they came to visit should you invite
their partners when leader said that he
would consider inviting them for dinner
and for a visit but not to stay I said
we have other children who are not
involved in the church we are in a big
city they may live here with their
girlfriends with their boyfriends they
may have children do we deny them access
to our homes I find it so offensive I
said in the meeting I'm just an ordinary
woman and my husband and I love our
children the best we can oftentimes we
make mistakes but it's hard for me to
see that our sense mistakes are greater
than those of our other children or ours
for that matter my belief is that God
loves them as much as he loves us and
more than we can really conceive for me
to make a judgment that our gay children
are not good enough to stay in our house
is inconceivable so I'm afraid the
church has not done very well with that
issue organizations move slowly it's
very difficult for me to say that the
church is always perfect and does
everything right it doesn't it's just
made up of people it's made up of some
very good people who try very hard
but they only understand what they
understand what we find with these
accounts is narrative a story in which
proposition 8 figures in changing the
direction of the story what we find this
ambiguity contradiction and some humor
as one woman concludes I often don't
know which side of the gay debate I'm on
personally I believe that our son's
same-sex marriage will be good for him
and good for society
his marriage will in no way undermine my
marriage for male-female marriage in
general on the other hand I believe that
a prophet stands at the head of our
church who has spoken out against
same-sex marriage it's a good thing I
have two hands these personal accounts
that the California marriage debate
shows some very reactions to political
issues when the church speaks the
response is never simple and in one
voice what people say in public under
the pressure of public opinion is not
necessarily what they would say
privately still these voices have great
value in recording strong views even
when they are not spoken at the time
these attitudes can be used as
historical evidence for attitudes and
behavior they may have a life later down
the line let's get all those opinions
and experiences recorded thank you